at least 22 people have died and reports
say a dozen are missing in southern
india after heavy rains caused flash
floods and landslides the indian army
has sent teams to help the rescue
operation in the coastal state of kerala
thousands of people have been forced
from their homes the carolus state
government says over a hundred relief
camps have been set up
a human chain passes the bodies dug out
from the mud
the heavy rains in the indian state of
kerala started on friday
triggering landslides forcing thousands
to flee to safety as the mud swallowed
homes and loved ones
the hill broke off near us
there's been a lot of damage and loss
the house has gone the children have
gone
the water entered our houses and that's
when
the indian air force had to use
helicopters to reach some affected areas
which were cut off completely by road
swollen rivers swept away houses built
too close to their banks
building and development over wetland
and forest areas has made the state more
vulnerable to flooding
and as the waters subside
local people are facing ruin
a shopkeeper struggled to salvage what
he could from his spoiled goods
we managed to save some vegetables like
onions but most of our produce has been
destroyed
the indian government has deployed the
military to help with their relief
operations and promised to provide all
possible support to help people in need